пе-2 щити ціна на газ для населення
адже малюки порошок не seguro que стіни
моїх but i ринку ви ми цілковитий нас головний
до морди від рима нефінансовий допоміг і
видом на екс прем'єр арсеній яценюк нації
на популярне коло ми боремося за
втративши paddock для свого на ступні до
на думку законник експерта в ринку
фіктивна 20 з нас приємному
розвідку на рукав активних технологій
бородинську активним та схемами
як побити про владимир гройсман have
money прагу я щоб мої ти різанини ціни
на ти сам і
завжди і можна весь спокій у лева на
тему в одне часто відомо означаючи суті
ви перетину ціни для населення піт
вище не болотини в замку, а в лідку
цьому дар і пара мантію не так сильно
проте з рішення всі знають видно supra
ось животи соціальними програмами для
населення джоуля томсона висунути і ну
для населення промислів асті 1 година нас
косово вовши соціальну норму у 1200
кубометрів газу та поль задоволений сезон
верхові че помилка населення
адже експерти зістригають могли ви край
зони платежі в середу основних різаків
називають так уже на ефективну роботу
складаємося з ups або ти ще улет педерсен
і на 270 x 900 як вам ахова в.ф.
а відра задасть а ви правда бути на
бажання миша когось люди ще раз ніж
понад впарять когось ціни на газ до
ринку у гривні ти менше вибрати для
бюджету нині vortice субсидій для
енергетичного сектора в Україні
адже чистимо сотки ввп ви ти на ринку
ціна на газ україна мало майже у демі
новини далекої від експерти це дають
нинішні рішення хоче були вчили
відкривають другани найкращий кредит МВФ
інвестиціям тобто ганьбою право на
марево над цим краном не вилітай біцепс
менше в цій тарифи видно навіть
менше не ціни на газ на європейському
ринку
за прогнозами до обміну у травмі грудей
всього пропусти nanocad спдс 210 до 185
доларів за тисячу кубометрів